president biden yes i'm just talking to
valerie has been in public service for
more than 50 years since winning his
first campaign for newcastle city
council in delaware that was back in 196
1970 rather and his younger sister
much younger sister valerie bynons has
been by his side the entire time she has
been a part of every one of his
political campaigns including his 2020
white house run and seven successful
senate races now she's out with a new
memoir and it's called growing up biden
something she knows a little bit about
she writes about being the only girl in
a family of brothers and one of the few
women at the table during much of her
career valerie biden owns joins us in
the studio now before you joined us on
camera valerie was saying where do i
look i wanted to say just look at me
with admiration and adoration that will
be don't look at the camera that'll be
easy just pretend it's just the two of
us chickens here but you know valerie
congratulations on your book because i
think you give us a lot of insight to
your brother give us a lot of insight
into your relationship
but when you guys were growing up you
you're he was when you did his first
campaign you were 25 26 yeah he's so he
the county council was 1970. he's three
years
older than i he used to be a lot older
until he wrote his book and exposed me
but you had no experience running
campaigns why did you think you could do
this and why did he trust you
well i have from from the time i opened
my eyes when i was a little girl my
brother had his hand out and he said
come on belle we've got things to do and
places to go and people to see
and i he took me with him every place
and when his his friends would say why
did you bring a girl his aunt said well
she's not a girl she's my sister yeah he
told me that whatever he could do i
could do better he said i was smarter
nicer kinder i was not all pot couldn't
possibly be true but he believed so much
in me
that i owed it to him and to myself to
try and be the young girl that he
thought i could be you know one of one
of the most telling stories to me in the
book was when you all were going to
college and the family didn't have
enough money
and they said
and would you tell this i think it's so
illuminating about who he is and who you
are you didn't have enough money for
both of you to go and so your brother
joe goes to your parents and says okay i
could go and commute yes uh and my
father sold cars so he was able to get a
car from the dealership at a reasonable
rate that i could commute back and forth
but uh i wanted to go and live on
colleen yeah
on campus
and my brother unbeknownst to me at the
time said come on i want to talk to dad
and mom and he said
look
i'm not going to go back
i'm going to finish college for sure
yeah but i'm going to take a year off
and earn enough money so that i can pay
for
my tuition and send val this year
he said let her go instead of me because
she's smarter
and she deserves to go yeah yeah he was
i mean
it was shocking and my father was
somehow uh found a way to
make it happen that we could both go my
father
very much wanted to be able to send us
but uh
my brother handled it with a great deal
of dignity and for my father and then he
was always looking out for you your
family is extremely close and you give
many instances of that and how the two
of you have protected each other and now
the family's in the news mainly because
of hunter biden and your brother is
hunter a problem for the family in your
opinion no now because
there's he certainly is under a
microscope and a lot of people are
looking at his business dealings
was it on the up and up was it not on
the up and up was joe biden involved was
jimmy biden involved what do you want to
say about that well
i mentioned it in the book and the only
race that i wasn't enthusiastic about
joe getting involved in was a 2020
presidency
because i expected and was not
disappointed that it would be ugly and
mean and it would be an attack on my
brother joe
personally and professionally because
the former president uh is
very intent on
bringing my brother down but what has
that got to do with hunter and well i i
assumed from the beginning that
that the former president and his
entourage would uh would uh attack my
brother by going
and attacking the family
and uh because of uh
all the the policies and the principles
that joe stood for but the but he
thought that the weak link would be you
know to attack my brother's child
and
you know hunter has written in exquisite
detail
about his struggle with addiction
his walk through hell
and i am so grateful that he's been able
to walk out of hell but i don't think
that there's a family in this country
who hasn't
tasted it or
felt
what it's like to
to see someone struggle with addiction
we're not talking about addiction though
we're talking about business dealings
and i'll move on from that do you think
there's nothing there's not a there
there in europe there hasn't been a
there there since it was mentioned in
2019 or whatever whenever it first was
you think your brother should run again
in 2024 sure yes i think my brother is
the right person at the right time for
all the right reasons and when you look
at a president or any leader
what you look for is temperament empathy
character integrity
and accomplishments and that makes joe a
a great leader and he should continue
thank you very much valerie you are
welcome thank you growing up biden goes
on sale tomorrow wherever you like to
buy your books we'll be right back